vamos a la revista de prensa con Rosa
Pérez más deudor Rosa Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela muchas noticias
esta mañana y para empezar aquí hay que
saber ante el juicio Fox dominio nos lo
cuentan New York Times exactamente Y es
que este juicio tenía que empezar ayer
pero finalmente se retrasó hasta hoy y
es un proceso que va a durar hasta
finales de mayo según Explica el New
York Times y lo principal es que la
empresa
dominio en botting systems que es una
empresa de sistemas de Voto electrónico
que se usa en Estados Unidos
concretamente se utilizó en 28 estados
en las elecciones de 2020
acusa no denuncia por difamación a la
cadena Fox news por haberla acusado de
mal funcionamiento en su retórica del
fraude electoral tras las elecciones de
2020 bien pero lo que está sin duda en
juego en todo este proceso son los
límites de la libertad de expresión y de
la protección de la primera enmienda en
Estados Unidos que es protege la
libertad de expresión para los medios de
comunicación y esto porque Ángela bien
pues porque en este juicio lo que está
por determinar no es si la información
que digamos difundió Fox news sobre el
fraude electoral y sobre que estas
máquinas funcionaban mal era falsa o no
esto en las audiencias previas el juez
ya lo ha dejado claro lo que hay que
definir es finalmente si Fox news era
consciente de que estaba difundiendo
esta información falsa por lo tanto sí
lo hizo con Mala Fe o no esta es un poco
la condición que va a acabar por
determinar si la cadena no difamó
conscientemente o no y es que
precisamente Qué dice Fox news dice que
sus periodistas están amparados por la
libertad de expresión sin embargo
mensajes internos que se han aportado
como pruebas para todo este proceso
muestran como presentadores de la altura
de Tucker carlson o como el propio
propietario no del grupo mardoc El que
tiene Fox news era en privado estaban
completamente convencidos de que tal
retórica del fraude electoral Pues
estaba infundada no Por lo tanto hay
indicios como decíamos de que sí que
estarían actuando con digamos otras
motivaciones que no la difusión de
información verídica sino más bien dar a
la audiencia lo que su audiencia quería
escuchar cuando veían que biden iba a
ganar esa contienda electoral Bueno
sobre este mismo tema del país titula
las mentiras de la Fox se sientan en el
banquillo Sí exactamente porque tal y
como señala Miguel Jiménez en el país
otra de las decisiones más polémicas del
juez es considerar que la cadena es
responsable de lo que decían algunos de
sus invitados y que no basta con que
otros invitados sostuvieran lo contrario
no además de ser la cadena responsable
de lo que decían sus presentadores
señala este el juez de este proceso que
la cadena también como decíamos es
responsable mentiras que hubieran
difundido algunos de sus invitados y me
parece relevante que esto pone sobre la
mesa la importancia de que no todos los
discursos son igual de válidos no Ángela
de que no se puede dar la misma
condición de veracidad No a todas las
opiniones y que pues la objetividad o el
equilibrio no se encuentra siempre
contraponiendo blanco y negro no Bueno
vamos a ver algunos expertos tal y como
señala este artículo del país están
divididos sobre Qué sería mejor para la
libertad de expresión y la libertad de
prensa en este caso algunos dicen que si
con tanta evidencia finalmente no se
acusa Fox news de difamación Pues que
esto puede suponer una mala precedente
para lo que es la desinformación y la
manipulación otros se señalan que si la
Fox pierde se abre la puerta a una
oleada de demandas que obliguen a los
medios a desvelar Los criterios de sus
coberturas y escribe el periodista hasta
las falsedades deben estar a veces
protegidas concluyen pues Mire es que
una cosa es la libertad expresión pero
también está otro concepto que es la
opinión informada no de los asuntos que
nos corresponden a nosotros como
periodistas así que bueno estaremos muy
atentos a ver de qué manera se
desarrolla iremos siguiendo este juicio
Ángela porque hay testimonios que sin
duda no nos vamos a querer perder no
Pero por supuesto que no ahora el
periódico francés Liberación cumple 50
años y usted ha hecho un repaso por sus
icónicas portadas y bueno queremos
verlos sí Hay muchísimas portadas Además
este medio es muy famoso por la calidad
tanto gráfica como por a los titulares
que eligen no en sus primeras páginas
hemos hecho solamente un breve repaso
Empezando por su primer número del 18 de
abril de
1973 en que escriben agarren su
periódico Francia se mueve liberan
liberemos la prensa hacia un nuevo
periodismo no y en la foto en el pie de
foto ponen una vida nueva un periódico
Nuevo está portada la que tú hacía
referencia en esta introducción Ángela
en segundo lugar hemos elegido por
ejemplo la del día que del 10 de
septiembre de 1975 en que escribieron
Oriente es rojo el sol se pone en
referencia a una frase de la Revolución
cultural pero esta portada nos explica
Liberación en esta timeline que pueden
buscar en su página web con las portadas
más destacadas de estos 50 años que fue
esta edición la que inauguró la
tradición de pensar la portada como un
cartel no que una una costumbre que han
ido repitiendo a lo largo de los años
dejándonos con portadas icónicas luego
En tercer lugar hemos elegido la caída
del muro de Berlín que fue el 9 de
noviembre recordemos de 1989 sin embargo
Liberación no la puso en portada hasta
el día 11 Y por qué porque su
corresponsal dice llamó a la redacción y
le dijeron Cálmate estamos en huelga
nadie se acababa de creer que estaba
realmente cayendo el muro de Berlín y
derribándose esa frontera y finalmente
el día 11 la ponen en portada con la
frase que historia tenemos en cuarto
lugar
es una portada que la hemos elegido por
su titular y es que Liberación Hace
muchos juegos de palabras se encuentra
palabras muy adecuadas en muchas
ocasiones y hemos seleccionado entonces
la portada del 1 de septiembre de 1997
tras el accidente de coche que acabó con
la vida de la princesa Diana en París y
que titularon con una foto de más no En
referencia Pues a que este accidente
tuvo lugar recordemos cuando la princesa
estaba siendo perseguida por los
paparachis tenemos la foto del 11 de
septiembre de 2001 es aportada digamos
sin ninguna palabra porque tal y como
explica Liberación no tenían palabras el
shock era inmenso solo la fecha
conscientes de que marcaba un antes y un
después dicen en el nuevo desorden
mundial luego hemos señalado también las
fotos las portadas de abril de 2002 que
volvieron digamos a relucir en las
últimas elecciones presidenciales cuando
Liberación claramente hizo Campaña en
contra de Jean marile penn que llegó por
a la segunda vuelta presidencial con
este gran no y con una la foto alentando
a la población a marchar el primero de
mayo en contra Pues de la extrema
derecha luego hemos seleccionado las
fotos las portadas que eligieron tanto
cuando ganó Obama en las elecciones
estadounidenses en 2008 como cuando ganó
Trump no está este contraste entre el
tenemos un sueño y el American Psycho
luego tenemos en la foto del 15 de
noviembre tras los atentados de París en
qué Liberación se volvió a quedar sin
palabras esta imagen que recordamos Aquí
también cuando se celebraron esos
juicios por los que Liberación hizo una
edición muy especial con los relatos de
los testigos de los supervivientes de
esa noche y vamos ya terminando con una
foto del con una portada del 3 de
diciembre de 2018 con macron sumergido
en amarillo en plena crisis de los
chalecos amarillos una foto una portada
que resuena mucho a día de y cerramos
con la portada del 4 de abril de 2022
que se tituló la barbarie cuando se
empezaron a descubrir tras La retirada
de las tropas rusas de las afueras de
kiev los crímenes de guerra contra
civiles particularmente en bucha no sé
si la vamos a ver para ya cerrar esta
sección Bueno aquí la tenemos en todo
caso estas han sido solamente algunas
pinceladas de estos 50 años de historia
en la portada de liberación pues miren
en general un bellísimo repaso más
postales para la historia que otra cosa
y gracias a usted Rosa gracias Ángela